Nucleus is micro kernel of a spring and it is subset of leap case prescription
as I mentioned just now. In the
sense that, nucleus manages only threads and IPC.
The abstractions available in nucleus are the
following. There is this domain. A domain is
similar to Unix process, it's a container, or
an address space, and threads can execute in
a particular domain. These threads are similar in semantics
to P thread that we have seen before, and this
abstraction called door, is a software capability to a
domain. It's you can think of it as a real
life analogy of. Opening a door in order to
get into a room. In a similar manner, if you
have a handle to the door you can open the
door and enter a target domain. So that's the idea
behind door. So, any domain can create
these nucleus entities called doors, which are essentially
entry points for entering the target domain.
With the object orientation, I told you that
the only thing that you can do is make invocations on objects, and the entry
points available and the objects that are contained
in a domain are represented by this abstraction
called door, that's provided by nucleus. Let's say, I'm a
file server. What will I do? Well I have entry
points in my file server, such as, opening a file,
or reading a file, writing a file, and so on.
Basically, I will create those entry points as doors into
my domain. And if I'm a client, how do I
get access to the entry point that's available in the
target domain? Well, the way I do that is exactly similar
to how you may be opening your file in a Unix file system. What you do is an f
open, and when you do that, you get a
file descriptor, which is a small integer that is a
handle for you to access that file. In a
similar manner. If I'm a client and if I want
the ability to invoke a target domain, a particular entry
point, then what I want is an access to this
door and the way I get that is by getting
a door handle. So I get a door handle. So
every domain will have this door table, which is similar
to the file descriptors that you may have in a
Unix process. And every door ID that you have in
this door table points to a particular door. If I
have a door handle in my door table for a
particular door, what that tells me is that, oh, I have
the ability. To, make an invocation in
the target domain that this particular door
corresponds to. So the possessor of a
door handle, is able to make object invocations
on the target domain using this door handle. And as you can see, a particular
client domain can have a door table
that has access to several different target domains.
So in this case, these two entries in my door
table points to this door, which probably are entry points
into this target domain. And other door, which are a
different set of entry points, and I have access to
them as well. And multiple clients may have access to
the same door, because if it's a file system, for
instance, you may be able to access the file system,
I may be able to access the file system, and
so on. So, the door table is something
that is unique to every domain and it gives
that domain an ability to access the entry
points in the target domain, so that they can
make object invocations. So, the way to think
about this door, it's basically a software capability to
a domain. Since we are using object orientation,
it is represented by a pointer. To a C++
object that represents the target domain. And door
can be passed from domain to domain but it
is a software capability and it can be passed
from domain to domain, and when it is passed
from domain to domain it gives the ability
for those domains to actually get access to the
entry points specified through the door, to the target
domain. And the spring kernel itself is a composition
of the nucleus plus the memory management, that is
inherent in the fact that these domains represent an
address space. Now, how do you go about making
an object invocation, that is, you want to make
a protected procedure call into a target domain from
a client domain. How do I do that? Well,
the nucleus is involved in every door call, so
they won't open the door. I need the permission
of the nucleus. And what I do is, when I make the invocation using the small
descriptor that I have, which is a door
handle, the nucleus looks at it, says okay this
domain has the ability to do this invocation.
And it allocates a server thread on the target
domain, and executes the invocation that is indicated
by this particular door handle. It's a protected procedure
call, and since it is procedure call semantics,
the client thread is deactivated, and the thread
is allocated to the target domain, so that
it can execute the invocation for the method
that is indicated by this door handle. And
on return from this target domain, once that
protected procedure call is complete, the thread is
deactivated. And the client thread is reactivated so
that the client can continue with whatever it was doing before. So, this is
very very similar to the communication mechanism
that we discussed in the lightweight remote
RPC paper before, in the sense that, we're doing very fast cross address space
calls using this door mechanism. This protected
procedure call is in illustration of how nucleus
makes sure that even though it has an object based design and it is using object
orientation in the building of the, in the,
it is using object orientation in the structuring
of the operating system kernel. It ensures that
it'll still be performant, in the sense that
you can do this cross domain calls very
quickly through this idea of deactivating the client
thread and quickly activating the thread to
execute the entry point procedure in the target
domain and on return reactivating the client thread.
And all of this results in very fast
cross address space calls through this lower mechanism.
That's how you make sure that you get
all the good attributes of object orientation and
not sacrifice on performance at the same time.